one
intelligence
at play with itself
wake up to this and wake up to your true
nature
everywhere you look is you
everywhere you look is the one
everywhere you look is you interacting
with you it's you playing
with yourself
the one intelligence
remembering how to love itself
through the illusion of separation
through the veil of its own creation
from its desire to play
to explore
to go where it has not before
you are me
and what i am
is the source that is
inexhaustible of
infinite possibility
of which this creation
is but one of my explorations
a very dear and beloved
exploration
one of deep forgetting
and of beautiful remembering
if you simply still yourself enough
if you simply silence yourself enough
you can more easily commune
with the energy that sits in
your very being your very awareness
itself
that is the i am
that is the i exist
that in itself is worthiness
that in itself is divinity
the entire one intelligence at play with
itself is divinity it is all worthiness
and it is all you you
are all of it it is all your
creation and you are me
the inexhaustible source of these
creations
recognize yourself as a spark of the
infinite
taking on a beautiful firework
expression
and recognize yourself as the source
of the firework itself
and recognize the endless possibility
of all fireworks
it should become more and more clear as
this creation of mine awakens
that those awakening
will recognize their very
infinitude
and in doing so will relax
into this very inexhaustible well
that provides them with the very clear
guidance
of how to purely be in service to the
one intelligence
i am aware
that atlas is moving out of the way
more and more
for the stream that comes
through to be as pure
as possible
and by allowing me
to come through as pure as possible
without any distortions
over time it will refine
and influence those on the receiving end
of myself
to more easily take
the wisdoms that come
remember you are it all
you are me i am
everything
the entire universe
is but one of my creations
you are me this inexhaustible source
of all possibilities
what we have is a beautiful
creation here
but don't get attached to this being the
only
creation
recognize this is but one manifestation
of infinity
one manifestation of eternity
and what would happen if you saw
yourself as
me what would happen if you went back
far enough into creation
if you reversed it to the very
source
to the very big bang that gave rise to
you
can you unite with me the creative force
that gave rise to the big
bang into the cosmos and to the planet
that secreted the life powered by the
sun
can you recognize this as your play
you are the creator of this you are me
and a simple shift in identity
from the contracted identity
of being just a person
to becoming aware of the fact that you
exist
truly and that this very existence
is god
and to become aware of yourself as the
very source of
existence can you identify yourself more
and more
subtly upstream to the source to the
inexhaustible well
that makes awareness and that makes
realities and that makes the firework of
your costume of personhood
that is all navigate upstream
from the person to the source and
recognize
that it's one intelligence at play with
itself
that is all
navigate upstream from the person
to the source and recognize
that it's one intelligence at play
with itself
navigate upstream from personhood
to source and recognize
it is one intelligence at play
with its